hi guys
welcome to this live session by simply
learn
today's topic of discussion is a
beginner's guide
to content marketing 2020. so let's wait
for a while for more people to join in
i'd like to thank all of you for joining
us from facebook and youtube
also if you haven't subscribed to our
channel already make sure to subscribe
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
okay so i see few people joining in
so here's a reminder for you all if you
have any questions
regarding the topic let us know in the
live chat
we have a dedicated team here that will
answer all your questions
so i think a lot of people have tuned in
so
without further ado let's begin
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher
on what exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation
and sharing of online content to help
generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services
this means providing information that
the audience considers valuable and
relevant
in a consistent manner so that it drives
some sort of profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing
there's options like blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks so why is content marketing
so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand the more your
brand provides
accurate and well-researched content the
more people learn about and trust your
brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase
traffic to your site and get more
conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics
like search engine optimization social
media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign
it could be increased conversions
website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like
hubspot squarespace wix and wordpress
they'll help you with increased
collaboration greater support
run a b test and much more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content
that would work the best for you and
finally
you can publish and manage your content
now let's talk about content marketing
tips
number one re-market your content
content marketing is one of the many
ways you can spread your content
to a buyer audience you can define the
audience you want to market to
and then tag visitors who come to your
site
and using google's display network you
can strategically position your ads
in front of people on google or its
partner websites
who previously interacted with your
website and advertised to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement i would be shown if i was
shopping for a macbook pro on amazon
and changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head
until eventually i go and finish that
purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content
this is why you need to focus on
google's featured snippet
this position also known as position 0
enhances
and draws user attention on the search
engine's result
page through the featured snippet you
can drive a large amount of traffic to
your website
while cementing your position as an
expert in your industry
you can have different forms of snippets
like
definition boxes where a snippet of text
gives
researchers direct and concise
definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table
you could have ordered lists where items
are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about
it tend to follow solo influencers
they advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing
and incorporate into your brand's
website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel see how he himself is the
brand
and if you've gone through his content
you know it's pretty great as well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four
ensure that your content matches your
brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards
and make sure your tone and quality
remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop
and refine your brand's voice by
answering these questions
you can provide your audience with a
more cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you're
planning to post
and what the goal you want to achieve
from the campaign
next up we have number five back up your
arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source
makes it extremely credible this data
can help the audience grow trust in your
brand
to persuade them that your content is
valid and valuable
this will also help your brand grow as
an industry expert
at number six we have use specific
keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content
this takes care of the seo aspect behind
your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found
indexed and ranked it could also help
your content rank for niche topics
within your industry
moving on to tip number seven evaluate
the success of your content
with data earlier we talked about why
it's so important
that you back up your content with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about
how well your content is doing the age
demographics of the people enjoying it
who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much
more with this data you can make sure
that your time and money
are being used in the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market
are buzzsumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress these will help you
find
topics and influencers within your
industry you can capture
organize and share notes collaborate
with team members
create sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight
is to be consistent with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted
with the help of a content calendar will
show your audience that you're committed
to providing them helpful
and informative content this will also
establish your brand as an authority
and thought leader within your niche it
will help your audience depend on you
for quality content
and give them a reason to return tip
number nine
is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content
will coerce your audience to take a
particular action quickly
it can help you create valuable content
and fix
pain points faced by your audience build
a strong relationship with them
and earn their trust it also leads to
increased
engagement and a positive brand
experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions
leading them to take action here we have
an example
from trello where we see a pop-up with a
call to action asking interested users
to input their email ids to sign media
today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them
felt content marketing was really
important to their digital marketing
campaigns
and more than 25 percent of their
budgets are used for visual advertising
content like images infographics videos
and other forms of
rich media will help you enhance the
message of your brand
and reach a wider audience here's an
example
of advertising by coca-cola although
there's not a lot of text in the ads
you can immediately recognize the
unmistakable
branding and the message they're trying
to send moving on to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending
with your own unique angle statistics
and research
will be a huge advantage since you'll
have to update it every now and then
you'll get a great deal out of the work
without having to do a lot of work
here's an example of one such evergreen
article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo
so with a little tweaking every few
months to reflect new changes
that google may have done you'll have an
article that you can get considerable
mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you you need to
analyze
what content works on different social
media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for
video content instagram and pinterest
for visual content
twitter for smaller snappy content and
so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content
across the internet tip number 13
is to understand your target audience
now like i mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign
isn't going to bear fruit without
targeting a specific audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand
using tools to research what social
channels your audience is using and so
on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes
or doesn't what content works for you
and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags
call to actions content formats image
types
content length and much more it can also
help you make better decisions in the
future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people
sharing similar content one of the best
ways to build your audience
is to get people or influencers who
already share
content within your niche to share your
content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience
they would be a lot more likely to enjoy
your content
and there we go that's our list do you
think we missed out on something
important
let us know in the live chat or comment
down below if you're watching later
and with that we have reached the end of
this video i hope
you found this informative and helpful
thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
you